biggest fashion regrets how could people
highlight their hair you know why would
they do that in a milk in years
hey guys I'm Barry sander i'm ashleigh
Crossan and welcome to you ryu 90 i'm
very excited about our guest on our
first episode mark McGrath
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the hello
[Music]
I'm so honored to be here Ashley's right
that's what happening Riu 90s might be
the greatest title ever okay well we
can't get started without having you
have to get in the 90 we have to get in
the 90s okay you brought we got our
nineties box we have our nineties box
right here add all kinds of 90s attire
we've got neon visors we've got
puka-shell necklace oh my god basically
I've got a funny story about these puka
shell necklaces one in 97 I wore a puka
shell necklace like everybody else did
and I am I'm so fat winter on me this
was a child yeah well they're all for a
child right when you think about it so I
had spooky Shawn necklace and fly kind
of hit I had some money for the first
time right so I was eating at nice
places and stuff and I'm like why is my
puka-shell necklace keep getting tighter
and I gained like 20 pounds like my fat
roll was coming over the puka-shell
necklace and so it's a good gauge of
what they're gaining weight or not or
whether you got a hit song in the 90s a
slap bracelet is so 90s
how many lap races are you putting on
five I'm going to restrict your use of
the 95 yeah you're having too much oh my
we got to get to some question let's
take it back all the way to the
beginning the origin story of Sugar Ray
yeah the origin of sugar a is we started
Newport Beach California in 1988 and the
local high school band was the band at
all the girls done a new Porter's van
called the Tories and I didn't have any
Talent
so don't have any talent anybody and but
I would follow the band to be we're
under the gun of the girls after that
band kind of disbanded we got they
thought of me said well he can't believe
saying but there's something there we
became a band called the Shrinky Dinks
in 1988 then we signed a record deal in
1994 to Atlantic Records and changed
their name from Sugar Ray to the from
the shrinking inks to Sugar Ray because
the shrinky dinks is a trademarked name
okay and we've got a licensing agreement
sent in the mail from their lawyers that
was Hasbro Mattel had said oh that's
great you're the shrinky dinks you want
to license our name that's great it's a
half million dollars a year and blah
blah blah
to the terms and like oh my god what are
we going to do so we called our 12 fans
and let them know we're or change your
name to sugar a and that's how the name
sugar II was born your first album was
was pretty hardcore it's funny the first
time we were like kids in candy stores
called lemonade and brownies and it was
released in 1995 hip hop explosion was
becoming huge it's a real sort of a new
sort of a kind of a new stranglehold hip
hop was taking a place on the charts and
in the suburbs you could feel it
something was happening and there was a
crossover between rock and and hip hop
and because we weren't the best players
were kind of turned everything up to 11
and had a little more aggressive harder
style some of the slowest songs ever did
on that record but some of the hardest
songs as well and that build up a little
bit of momentum which led to the record
floor which had
[Music]
and why was the first time really well
if it had some meaning that wasn't just
was about beer girls fast cars all very
important I relate to all of all very
important subjects but why would the
first one that's real meaning to it back
my first heard the version I heard of it
you know it was just to a loop and had
the course it was like oh I almost quit
the band I can't go away but I looked at
the song I wrote verses to it and put
together kind massage a little and a
team effort came out and fly happened
and it was great one sublime fit with
what I got
sublime and their producer David Kahn
really cracked the code of how to mix
reggae hip hop rock and that whole
Southern California snowboard skateboard
lifestyle all in one and make it mean
something so we said yes please did love
you David Kahne and luckily he got a
hold of fly and made it what it was
without his production skills in that
thing we wouldn't you wouldn't be
talking me today what was that time like
when fly came out and you realized it
was becoming a huge hit it was the
greatest feeling in the world it's all
into number one we were on MTV I was on
covers of magazines
we're selling records we had money all
these dreams came true for buying houses
and and and another thing I think the
biggest thing for all of us was like
this is this is going to be a career now
and it's funny because everybody changes
around you people say you change but you
know it's kind of a cliche to say but
everybody has changes around you they
don't know how to act around you which
is interesting and so it's a whole new
world to get used to on a Friday I could
walk to any mall on any America and no
one cared not at Monday I couldn't walk
through without being mom so what's
interesting it was fun being the mark
McGrath's guy for a while and having the
highlights and being the you know the
90s douchebag bullseye it was fun it was
a good time but that goes away with the
music's days that's why I'm talking
today I know it looks like you keep
disparaging the band I'm like look at my
hips you guys mad it's like well it's a
way for me to tell you how great we are
yeah I mean listen you don't write two
number ones for top ten that's six top
40 can sell 10 million records if you
stop
let's go some people are going really -
sighs where's the a black sheep here you
know so I guess it's gonna be on our
best behavior
god there's not camera Falls background
is my god I know do I think about yeah
well there's the thing where I like cut
out this little kid and use a word I
shouldn't have about well actually he's
the guy called me sugar gay okay I
insulted me but the kid was like 12 but
98 99 and I walked my Donecker card he
watches from the cheek and you know and
all these cameras are going off it's
just Madonna drives away they turn them
and I got in his face like ba ba ba ba
ba and it was like I blew up on him it's
ugly stupid things I'm not a tough guy
you know they try to get you to do that
what I did it
welcome to next day was under game
tonight it was on everything you know
sugar a guy blows up and not a Madonna's
new boyfriend sugar a guy blows up on
paparazzi so I I learned a life lesson
right there and if that kids out there I
apologize now he should have done I'm
not a tough guy but it's something that
comes up every six months some some
online radar or someone I won't get open
well-posed got again to say like it's
fresh and then go what it would a loser
man come on like it was 20 years ago I
made a [ __ ] bag let it go so my point
being is that boy I'm glad there was a
camera phones back then because I
already I made mistakes then okay when
there wasn't any today would be able to
may be too much to handle yeah cuz I
like that my phones people know but uh
thankfully you know put all my body
parts and made it out alive but yeah
I've made some I've done some dumb
things when you're well documented
well what's an ID with being attached to
Madonna but not attached to Madonna
what's one hookup from the 90s that
people don't know about
first of all Madonna wasn't what wasn't
a hookup yeah I let that thing breathe
for a while because it was great for me
I don't like tell the truth about that I
was going to be the one to say no I'm
not mad yeah come on man are you kidding
me so yeah we let that one breathe
tomorrow we still let that one breathe
we're talking about it now so well I was
telling I was telling you before we got
out here that I went and saw you guys
for the summer for my birthday
hey and it was so amazing because you
came out on stage and you were like
we're gonna play some new stuff guys
guys I need you guys to like take us
seriously and everyone's just kind of
like okay and perspective and then you
were like I'm just kidding were gonna
play why 11 we're going to open with it
we're gonna play in the middle and
and on course I'll fly it was funny
because you know there's some bands it
like sting well up like well like
reinterpret their hit so yeah I guess
you have as many as thing does you can
do that but you know to me if you're
going to come see a greatest hits
package we're going to play a song as
you want to hear that I am never ever
ever bored of performing me songs live
and I hear people say that I'm like do
you see the reaction you get after
performing that that is a drug you
cannot buy if you can't even touch it
I'm telling if there's one person in the
audience which seems to be the way
things are heading for Sugar Ray uh I
will still be performing me song it'll
be making you know we're good and you
know I heard you loud and clear there
you have a favorite song to perform you
know I people react so hardcore to flies
you know they're they're really - I mean
I can see every morning's great -
because it was number one as well um and
Sunday's great too because number three
okay well what is over I found by the
way don't call your last hit song when
it's over
let it's home that's the time
it might be a bit of a self-fulfilling
prophecy so think about that bands out
there ah yeah those are elastic but the
hips link means something to someone so
there's four times in our set where you
can really see the energy there's like a
sea change the amongst the people and
these others I saw I could see this and
like that you know I'm sorry Canadian
board rolls with their I could go to
doctor no I'm a jalebi but that is so
much fun you know actually that's that's
when you just class is so great this
still I mean still there's still meaning
of what we're doing you know um
it is a job you know and I'm fortunate
to call it that but there's meaning to
it and it means a lot to people and like
I love God
I'm disparaging the man I'm self
effacing and make fun of it but I know
how much do songs many people and that
to me I always hold shape there's one
more nineteen element we need to get to
yes the fashion yes the fashion biggest
fashion regret how could people
highlight their hair you know why would
they do that in a milk in years
haha let's get a gray or Seacrest blonde
it's funny Scott Weiland was my
inspiration maybe rest his soul for the
highlight I saw annoying stone a picture
of him headlining Madison Square Garden
and he had this suit on and his hair was
dirty it was jet black and a little like
like a stunk streak right here and like
that's the coolest thing ever and I had
a buddy who's going to beautician school
and this was 96 and fly ahead and hit
yet alright and about to shoot the video
for fly the next day I want a new
hairstyle
you know me before they booked like a
good day for and let's get your drunken
buddy from beauty school become dye your
hair he goes yeah dude I think I can do
this
so I went okay he eats our dye my hair
and blah blah blah I couldn't see it and
and and he's doing stuff back here
they'll be here like what are you doing
you know I think I'm gonna put dye back
here I don't know no dude just the one
thing goes alright alright I'll cover it
up and you don't just cover that up a
long story short boom he pulls it off
and it's that hair doing that you see in
flash and I remember my buddy who
directed flying make she was like what
what did you do do you just ruin the
whole that you just ruin the whole video
lucky there was a girl there on site who
knew how to cut hair a little bit and I
guess it turned into something because
after that after fly hit stuff people
were asking for
the Sugar Ray haircut yes and salon to
stuff a highlights now we laugh it I
mean they were fighting words like in
two thousand four and five and six I
mean God people are to beat me up for a
band highlights you know it's like
insane and now that we had a little bit
distance between the 90s you know people
are warming up to it I like to thank
sugar a little something do with your
well lasting legacy
you're still touring so performing but
why don't we get new music consider day
two of the original guys left a couple
years ago you know and it doesn't feel
like it's not the original for guys so I
put out an EP about a year and a half
ago mark McGrath solo EP just for fun
there's not a big market for bands there
are famous now
so bras is kind of a niche thing there
will be new music and sugar and jizz
when and when that's the question why
did the two band members leave the
triggers part-time jobs you know I'm
saying it got to a point where you know
people had to look for other things to
do and it's something you have to love
it's just weren't inserting performing
live it didn't end as as well as I hoped
it would we became that depressing
fourth stage and ever behind the music
you see you know when I said we wouldn't
be coming tonight he's been watching
like a loverboy going and then they sued
each other like we're not going to do
that ever right guys never we became
that sort of depressing cliche luckily
we know we've worked it out and
everybody's moved on and and that's the
good news
favorite part is if we want to go see
Sugar Ray we pretty much can like all
the time the summer the spring it's
really cool you know there's been
obviously a resurgence of an I&D so for
some reason this guy right here is uh is
this like you know it's great I've got
it I got a show I do on Sirius XM radio
called mark McGrath's 1:20 and we kind
of look back at you know songs of the
90s and I've so tell stories and things
that have also been fortunate to hook up
with I love the nineties tour which is
everybody from Vanilla Ice to Naughty by
Nature - all for one upper one salt and
pepper
Color Me badd young MC Tom look all
these great great bands and we go out
there we play just a hit I promise you
people if you come to this you will have
the most fun you'll ever have in your
life
battle of the nineties towards a lot of
points well check the website if you
want to come absolutely Louie so fun
this was our first and probably best
thanks for having you guys I'm honest